Wir reden hier ja immer mal wieder über verschwörungstheorien und eine die neuerdings ganz vorne mit dabei ist wird von den sogenannten
flachland verbreitet menschen die tatsächlich der festen überzeugung sind dass die erde nicht rund sondern flach ist ein eisring darum
schlüssel der ozeane und vielleicht ist über diese sogar auch noch eine glaskuppel
Ohmann ihr habt euch dieses thema whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle facts zum thema was genau steckt hinter dieser wilden
verschwörungstheorie und wie kann man sie auch einfach widerlegen herzlich willkommen bei distanzen fiction
Roman wenn ich das schon höre ja erstmalig auch skeptisch aber dann
Habe ich ganz viele youtube videos gesehen er mensch hier auf youtube gibt so viel viel infos und
falschinformationen nur weil irgendjemand irgendetwas überhaupt ist es noch lange nicht, wahr
Und nur weil der horizont für unsere augen nicht gekrümmt erscheint ist die erde noch lange nicht flach es funktioniert einfach nicht es ist unmöglich
Wenn man im netz den begriff flatrate eingibt findet man unzählige videos
blogbeiträge oder forum diskussion es gibt facebook gruppen mit den namen flache erde wissens gemeinschaft oder
Flache erde gegen global es die die nämlich an einer runden erde festhalten werden als globus köpfe
Bezeichnet dort heißt es dann zitat
Unsere erde ist flach und stationär sie rotiert nicht und ist definitiv keine google wie man uns von klein auf erzählt hat wir kennen die
unzähligen und nachvollziehbaren fakten und beweise der flachen erde und die gründe der globus
Lüge die seit fast 500 jahren aufrecht erhalten wird
Die flache gestalt der erde setzte
kreative gestaltung und intelligente schöpfung voraus was den menschen aber extra verheimlicht und
Vorenthalten würde ja und die intelligente schöpfung hat dann mal eben die naturgesetze außer kraft gesetzt oder was auch wenn sich die anhänger dieser
überzeugung inhaltlich nicht immer ganz einig sind sie alle sind der festen überzeugung
Verschwörer wollen das wissen um die ware ehrt form verheimlichen ihr beweis für die flache erde
Der blick aus dem flugzeug denn dabei ist die krümmung der erde ja gar nicht sichtbar
Im netz werden bilder von einem himmel der natürlich flach erscheint als beweis für ihre theorie diskutiert und über nasa bilder
spekuliert die eine runde so zeigen und deswegen ja wohl ganz klar gefälscht sein skepsis
Gegenüber allem alle wirklich alle hinweise auf eine runde erde werden umgedeutet oder einfach gleich
unglaubwürdig gemacht dagegen wird jede kleinigkeit die man als hinweis auf einen
Flachen horizont deuten könnte direkt als sicherer beweis gesät so wie es von allen verschwörungstheorien
Ja, bekannt ist dagegen steht der astronom galileo galilei der anfang des 17 jahrhunderts gezeigt
Hatte dass die erde eben nicht das zentrum. Des universums ist schon nikolaus kopernikus meinte das
1992 hat dann auch die kirche galilei rehabilitiert denn sie hatte damals seinen lehrern verboten dieses weltbild können wir heute
live von den bordkameras der internationalen raumstation iss
anschauen oder wenn die falcon heavy startet oder oder oder
und wie ihre maske letztlich fragte warum gibt es eigentlich keine flach marsianer und
trotzdem sehen dass die flach ertler nicht und berufen sich auf den britischen schriftsteller
samuel
robotern er hatte 1881 ein buch namens, zed tätig astronomie
globe veröffentlicht seine frau führte diese weltanschauung fort und gründete nach europa heimste eine erste society
Die erste gesellschaft der flachen erde wurde 1956 gegründet und existiert noch heute sie, zählt etwa
550 mitglieder wie schon gesagt
inhaltlich sind sich die anhänger dieser verschwörungstheorie
nicht immer einig einige glauben an eine endlose scheibe die sich nach oben bewegt wieder andere stellen sich einen tiefen
untergrund der ert schreiber vor alle blätter wie die anhänger dieser verschwörungstheorie auch genannt werden gehen aber
Vom ewigen eis der antarktis aus dass den rand der ert
Fläche umgibt das zentrum der nordpol
und genau
Das ist in ihrer vorstellung eben auch der grund warum das wasser von der erde nicht ins leere feld in dem sinne die große frage
Wie kann diese verschwörung sie konkret widerlegt werden in der wissenschaft geht man ja nach dem sogenannten
Sparsamkeit prinzip vor deswegen gilt die beste erklärung ist oft die einfachste auf die flache angewandt also stellt
man sich automatisch so einige fragen wie genau kommen die unzähligen bilder zustande und c
Die eindeutig beweisen dass die erde rund ist so viel kann man gar nicht auf einmal fälschen
Warum gegen genau auch davon weltweit milliarden menschen aus warum
Sollten wir alle hintergangen werden und warum ist dies noch nicht aufgefallen wie passt das zusammen
Dass alle anderen planeten kugelförmig sind nur die erde soll es nicht sein warum sind gerade das zentrum und der rand also arktis und antarktis
kalt
fragen über fragen und da wird es dann ziemlich kompliziert und genau hier geraten die flach eppler ins stocken oder
aber müssen ewig weit ausholen das wird dann, so
kompliziert und überhaupt nicht mehr einfach ich frage mich zum beispiel wie sie erklären wollen wie es bei einer flachen erde tag und nacht geben
kann, zeitzonen und so weiter oh mann anstatt ganz einfach
Zu sagen okay die erde ist eine kugel und nicht flach das ist nämlich ziemlich simpel und einfach also falls
er keine videos mehr von pixum verpassen wollt dann endet also ich werde kein video mensa flachländer machen also
andere themen dann endet hier meine whatsapp nummer dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert und zur begrüßung
Gibt es ein kleines goodie einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit auch dafür draufklicken kopf einschalten bei
verschwörungstheorien das hilft nämlich ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran